denise new concerns after the clark
county school district commits to a
hybrid learning start date but it's only
for some
students and staff 8 news now reporter
kristen drummond has been closely
following the developments and has the
latest
a lot of pressure recently on the clark
county school district to bring students
back on campuses there's been ongoing
concerns about mental health during
isolation since buildings closed last
march
i need our educators right to be able to
put their
their eyeballs on our kids
superintendent dr jesus jarrah takes
steps to reopen classrooms for
pre-kindergarten to third grade students
selecting march first as the day to
return
we needed to put that firm date out so
we can move forward
up and get our educators and prioritize
for the vaccines one of many
considerations when transitioning to the
hybrid instructional model for the
district's youngest students
an approach combining in-person and
online learning
we have been working with our principals
we had over 26
listening sessions and conversations
about our hybrid plan with our
principals
no timeline though when older students
can choose that option
safe assumption to strategically and
carefully move up
the grade levels in the meantime all
schools can choose to bring small groups
on campus for academic
emotional and social support those small
groups will continue
while hybrid starts absolutely but some
parents like brandi had to remain
concerned about the choices
i'm not sending my children back she
plans to choose full-time distance
education for her third grade daughter
she developed miss c from covid
and seven months later she's still very
very very sick
hecht worries about the potential spread
in buildings but dr jarrow remains
confident about the protocols in place
to keep staff and students safe kristen
drummond 8 news now
kristin thank you lower elementary
school families need to fill out a
questionnaire before 6 p.m tomorrow
night
the options are two different cohorts or
full-time distance education
a link to do so can be found on our
website eight newsnow dot com